no
ah
i
pudiera ser cualquiera de nosotros
qué pensamientos le vienen a la cabeza
cuando les digo la palabra migración
pensamientos de solidaridad
algunos prejuicios que sentimientos le
generan
la migración definida por la
organización internacional para las
migraciones como toda persona que se
desplaza o se ha desplazado a través de
una frontera internacional o dentro de
su propio país
dejando su lugar habitual de residencia
esto independientemente de su condición
jurídica del carácter voluntario
involuntario de su desplazamiento de las
causas de su desplazamiento o el tiempo
en que dura su estancia
a veces cuando hablamos de migración lo
vemos desde una perspectiva 'negativa'
dejando de lado todas las grandes
oportunidades que puede traer consigo y
hoy voy a hablarles del poder del
migrante y la gran oportunidad que tiene
para transformar la realidad de su gente
vivo en caracas venezuela- y hace tan
solo diez años cuando poníamos sobre la
mesa el tema de la migración era
absolutamente ajeno a nuestro gentilicio
era cercano porque en venezuela habíamos
recibido una gran comunidad de españoles
colombianos italianos portugueses pero
históricamente el venezolano no había
sido migrante y hoy tenemos una realidad
muy distinta hoy la gran mayoría del
país se ha preguntado al menos una vez
si es momento de hacerlo
o se ha hecho preguntas como me la ha
hecho yo y todos los de mi generación de
si estamos perdiendo nuestra juventud si
podemos tener una mejor calidad de vida
en otro lugar o si podemos generar más
valor en otro lugar
y el complejo
porque si soy un venezolano que vive en
venezuela pero que ha vivido tantas
historias y que ha acompañado tantas
historias de migración de familiares y
amigos que se ha preguntado tantas veces
si es el momento de irse y que vive en
una ciudad que ya no es lo que fue
porque al final las ciudades y los
países son su gente gente que se ha ido
que también me siento inmigrante aún
estando
salir y empezar en un nuevo país desde
cero en un lugar que no es tuyo en un
lugar que no conoces es difícil pero
también es difícil dejar atrás lo que es
tuyo lo que conoces
te imaginas terminar con tu pareja aun
estando enamorado
cómo te sentirías o qué harías si
tuvieras que emigrar y no quieres
hacerlo uno de los sentimientos que unen
a los migrantes o que podemos conseguir
en los migrantes es cómo se sienten con
respecto a su país al país que están
dejando
y sobre todo aquellos casos cuando los
migrantes se van
por alguna condición política económica
o social que está en contra de su
calidad de vida e incluso en algunos
casos en contra de su capacidad de
subsistencia a veces queremos o
cometemos el error de ver el tema de la
migración como algo muy pequeño pero
según el portal sobre datos mundiales de
las migraciones para el año 2019 hay más
de 271 millones de migrantes en el mundo
entero eso sí lo convertimos un país en
la población de un país representa el
cuarto país con mayor población
precedido por china india y los eeuu en
un número inmenso no es solamente un
tema de venezuela o de siria o yo de los
países en el pasado que tuvieron grandes
flujos migratorios es un tema que es muy
actual y que está creciendo año tras año
y por eso ahora lo quiero conectar
cuando hablaba con la nueva oportunidad
porque los migrantes pueden tener el
poder y la fuerza para transformar desde
su nueva localidad el sistema completo y
esto lo puede hacer primero enfocándose
en su estabilidad
es muy difícil ayudar al otro si no
estamos estables migrar es un proceso
complejo lleno de muchos retos hay unos
que los logran otros no lo logran se
tienen que regresar pero no podemos
ayudar a los nuestros a nuestras
familias a nuestros amigos a nuestro
país si nosotros no estamos estables y
la estabilidad no es solamente económica
e inclusive psicológica tu poder se
sustentará en tu estabilidad segundo
tenemos que aportar toda nuestra
capacidad para el país que estamos
llegando cuando uno sale de su país uno
se convierte un embajador de lo que es y
eso trae una gran responsabilidad y
cierta flexibilidad porque nos tenemos
que adaptar a nuevas palabras nuevas
costumbres nuevas tradiciones pero nunca
podemos dejar atrás nuestra esencia
porque al final nuestra esencia es la
que enriquece el proceso migratorio
cuantos en el mundo migrantes no han
traído premios nobeles a los países que
los reciben cuantos no han construido
empresas generando riquezas y empleos
cuantos nos han convertido emprendedores
sociales que han abogado por el
desarrollo social del país del lugar
tu poder ser utilidad en la medida en
que pueda generar mayor valor es el
lugar donde estás también tenemos que
tejer redes de solidaridad necesitamos
redes solidaridad cuando llegamos a los
nuevos países buenos nuevos territorios
para construir y crear capital social el
capital social no es más que un conjunto
de normas obligaciones valores actitudes
que facilitan la acción colectiva de
personas y organizaciones para generar
bienestar común y esta generación de
bienestar común a través de relaciones y
redes de confianza permite la generación
de recursos reales o potenciales reales
porque si nosotros estamos conectados
podemos establecer negocios por ejemplo
o potenciales porque podemos conocer qué
es lo que hace cada uno de nosotros y
sabemos que tenemos la potencialidad de
poder crear algo por lo tanto tu poder
se fortalecerá por las relaciones que
establezca también podemos repensar el
sistema como comunidad migratoria y
podemos tener influencia en ese sentido
no es para nadie secreto que nuestro
sistema global pareciera que está fuera
de control
el profesor schwab el fundador del foro
económico mundial define las migraciones
como una serie de elementos que están
interconectados de manera coherente para
lograr un resultado y los migrantes son
parte de ese elemento de ese sistema y
tienen la fuerza y la capacidad y el
autoritas y el conocimiento para poder
intervenir el sistema y hacer algo
porque muchas veces cuando hablamos
emigrante le dejamos la carga a ellos
pero el sistema puede que esté en contra
de que ellos puedan evolucionar y que
puedan crecer por lo tanto tu poder
también te permitirá transformar el
sistema global
pudiera saber que está sentado al lado
de ustedes pudieran ser ustedes pueden
hacer tú o pueden que se actúa estamos
en momentos delicados que nos exigen a
todos una gran responsabilidad de lo que
pensamos lo que decimos y lo que hacemos
a veces las generalizaciones pueden
tener los efectos de un arma o de una
bomba veamos la migración desde una
perspectiva positiva porque al final la
migración lo que promueve es la
diversidad y la diversidad trae consigo
la tolerancia y el trabajo conjunto para
buscar soluciones a los problemas con
distintos puntos de vista pudiera ser
cualquiera de nosotros muchas gracias
[Aplausos]